breaking news alert  thank you for joining us i'm john  langler we start with breaking news and  a deadly day so far on our roads here's  a live look right now charleston and  pecos scene of a deadly hit and run  crash you can see it is completely  closed it's been that way for some time  now metro police say that this hit and  run collision happened just before seven  o'clock this morning there you see the  location just east of downtown  charleston and pecos metro police say a  bicyclist was hit and killed by a semi  truck and the truck driver left the  scene  as you mentioned right now charleston is  still closed both directions around the  crash site near pecos so if you're in  that area if you have to go near that  area try and find another way around